[Aplausos]
[Música]
con los números en la mano no hay dudas
polonia nivel mejor momento de toda su
historia desde que en 1989 se
convirtiera en el primer país del mundo
en abandonar por completo el comunismo
colonia ha experimentado todo un milagro
económico queridos amigos de visual
político 1991 y mira que ha llovido fue
el último año estrictamente malo para la
economía polaca hasta la llegada del
coronavirus mientras que en el resto de
europa se han registrado muchos
altibajos por el camino desde 1992 la
economía polaca ha crecido todos y cada
uno de los años a una media anual por
encima del 4% ni la crisis asiática ni
la crisis de las puntocom y la gran
crisis financiera ni la crisis de la
deuda europea han hecho mella los
cimientos económicos de polonia e
incluso ahora el impacto del conavi nos
parece que va a ser moderado según el
fmi la economía polaca se recuperará
rápidamente de la crisis de coronavirus
esto es precisamente lo que explica que
en paridad de poder adquisitivo esto es
teniendo en cuenta el nivel de precios
la renta per cápita polaca se encuentra
ya prácticamente al nivel de portugal y
muy cerquita de españa para que os
hagáis una idea desde la caída del
comunismo el tamaño de la economía por
la casa multiplicado ni más ni menos que
por 8
fijaos
y no se trata sólo del pib todos los
indicadores han mejorado con creces
hasta el impacto del coronavirus las
exportaciones han ido viento en popa la
creación de empleo vacía récords casi
cada nuevo año y por ejemplo desde 1993
la productividad de los trabajadores por
la cosa multiplicado por tres es algo de
lo que os hablamos ya en un pasado vídeo
aquí en visual político en cierto modo
por lone se está convirtiendo en algo
así como la nueva alemania de europa una
nueva potencia industrial y exportadora
un escenario muy pero que muy diferente
al que se respiraba en 1989
[Música]
la gota roja amigos entre 1945 y 1989
esto es durante casi 45 largos años
bolonia estuvo bajo el control de la
unión soviética durante ese tiempo los
polacos no pudieron elegir el tipo de
gobierno o el modelo político económico
o social todo absolutamente todo venía
impuesto desde moscú a través del
partido comunista de polonia el conocido
como partido unido de los trabajadores
polacos sin embargo esperar un momento
porque aún con todo lo cierto es que el
sistema en polonia fue uno de los menos
extremos o totalitarios del lado
oriental del telón de acero entre otros
motivos por la presión internacional
porque los polacos se sentían sobre todo
ciudadanos centroeuropeos y porque la
sociedad civil era más fuerte o mejor
dicho al menos en cierto modo existía y
eso pues ya era mucho decir además la
iglesia católica tenía mucho peso en el
país y digamos que en cierto modo daba
cobijo ideas muy distintas a las que
procedían desde moscú
[Música]
todos estos elementos permitieron que en
la entonces república popular de polonia
existiese cierta oposición que surgieran
movimientos como el sindicato
solidaridad que la tierra apenas se
colectiviza 'va o incluso que las
autoridades polacas intentarán probar
suerte con la introducción del
socialismo de mercado un planteamiento
político que consistía en tratar de
aplicar los principios de mercado a las
economías de planificación central
[Música]
lo que por supuesto no funcionó en
absoluto el caso es que pese a todo pese
a tener un régimen menos radical o
totalitario los años 70 y 80 fueron años
también muy duros tanto desde el punto
de vista político como económico por
ejemplo a finales de los años 80 la
expresión más popular el acné emma no lo
tenemos digamos que era la expresión que
se repetía una y otra y otra vez en las
tiendas en los quioscos las tascas
porque básicamente la carencia de los
productos más elementales era enorme
[Música]
y si la expresión y emma era quizás la
más popular o al menos la más repetida
por su parte una de las principales
actividades en el día a día consistía en
hacer colas inmensas y largas colas en
las que podías pasarte horas y horas
esperando poder comprar algún producto
que se rumoreaba había llegado ese
establecimiento es difícil de hecho
encontrar un testimonio sobre la vida en
polonia socialista donde nos haga
referencia precisamente a estas inmensas
colas es algo que ha quedado grabado a
fuego en el imaginario colectivo
[Música]
luego a la carencia de productos de todo
tipo a las largas colas y a los cortes
de electricidad y agua que eran
relativamente frecuentes éste añadió a
finales de los 80 el problema de una
inflación que prácticamente rozaba los
niveles de hiperinflación amigos casi 45
años después de implantarse el modelo
socialista de inspiración soviética la
economía polaca estaba simple y
llanamente destrozada pero llegados a
este punto puede que os estáis
preguntando pero enrique si ésta era la
situación que se envía en la polonia de
finales de los años 80 como demonios
pudieron cambiar las cosas tan rápido
como pasó polonia de ser una economía
prácticamente arruina va a convertirse
en uno de los mayores milagros
económicos de toda europa en los últimos
50 años como logran los polacos dar el
salto del comunismo al capitalismo pues
atentos
la transformación el plan valiero bic
amigos la crisis económica la creciente
oposición y la apertura impulsada por
mijail gorbachov terminaron provocando
que 11 todos los regímenes comunistas
comenzaran a desmoronarse el polaco fue
uno de los primeros el día 1 de enero de
1990 el técnicamente primer gobierno
post comunista comenzó a aplicar un
revolucionario plan de reformas para
cambiar el país de arriba abajo hablamos
de uno de los programas de reforma
económica más revolucionarios y
profundos jamás emprendidos en todo el
mundo su objetivo transformar todo lo
rápidamente que fuera posible una
economía basada en el socialismo la
planificación central y la propiedad
estatal de los medios de producción para
convertirla en una pura economía
capitalista fue el conocido como plan
balcerowicz en honor al state by zero
big ministro de finanzas de la época y
padre arquitecto ideólogo de esta
radical transformación
[Música]
le chevalier o vi que era un joven
economista de 42 años que se había
doctorado en la escuela central de
planificación y estadísticas de varsovia
y que había pertenecido al poderoso
partido único de los trabajadores
polacos hasta que decidió abandonarlo en
1981 durante sus estudios
investigaciones académicas balsero bica
había leído probablemente de forma
clandestina obras de mises hayek en
torno al debate sobre el cálculo
socialista fue algo que tuvo según el
mismo ha comentado una gran influencia
en su forma de pensar gracias a ella se
entendió que los derechos de propiedad y
los mercados libres resultaban
esenciales para que un sistema de
precios racionales pudiera funcionar y
coordinar el sistema económico
además valiero vic también estudió
minuciosamente las reformas de ludwig
erhard el líder político alemán que
lideró los cambios que provocaron el
conocido como milagro económico alemán
de la república federal alemana tras la
segunda guerra mundial
pues bien el caso es que con todos estos
mimbres el bono de balsero byc se
propuso poner patas arriba polonia y
vaya si lo consiguió
a finales de 1989 el primer ministro del
primer gobierno pues comunista thaddeus
más suave le ofreció a nuestro
protagonista de hoy el cargo de vice
primer ministro y ministro de finanzas
para reproducir en polonia lo que se
logró en la república federal alemana
amigos era la única vía no sólo de
lograr escapar de la pobreza y recuperar
la prosperidad sino también incluso de
salvar la incipiente democracia nos
hallamos ante una alternativa dramática
o bien continuamos la marcha hacia una
economía mejor o bien damos por perdidos
todos los logros ya conseguidos y
volvemos al caos le chevalier obika ante
el parlamento polaco durante la defensa
de su plan de ajuste pensad que en aquel
momento el desmoronamiento de los viejos
sistemas políticos comunistas se estaba
convirtiendo en una crisis aún más
acusada tan sólo en dos años en polonia
la producción industrial se había
reducido casi un 40% la hiperinflación
asomaba amenazante y casi un millón y
medio de personas habían perdido su
empleo el colapso era total y la escasez
el común denominador ahora bien dicho
esto en qué consistió exactamente el
plan que se diseñó para salvar polonia
pues veréis el plan del 0 bits busco
hacer muchas cosas a la vez el día 6 de
octubre de 1989 se presentó en
televisión y en diciembre se aprobó en
el parlamento un extenso paquete
compuesto por 11 leyes que iban a
cambiar para siempre la historia de
polonia la primera fue la ley de
economía financiera dentro de las
empresas estatales que en aquel momento
eran quienes controlaban la inmensa
mayor parte de la economía polaca esta
ley por ejemplo exigió que las empresas
se gestionarán con criterios de mercado
y permitió que las grandes empresas
públicas pudieran declararse en quiebra
si no eran autosuficiente deberían
reorganizarse o liquidar se luego en
segundo lugar estaba la ley bancaria y
entre otras cosas prohibió que el banco
central financiará el déficit del
gobierno y restringió mucho la creación
de nueva moneda es decir para
entendernos paro en seco la máquina de
imprimir billetes
[Música]
por su parte las leyes de crédito y de
impuestos por el aumento salarial
excesivo que eliminaron los privilegios
de las empresas públicas a la hora de
recibir créditos impidieron que los
salarios públicos pudieran crecer
excesivamente la nueva ley tributaria
por su lado introdujo entre otros
cambios en la tributación común para
todas las empresas aboliendo los
recargos impuestos especiales que gravan
a las empresas privadas y suprimiendo
los privilegios que tenían las
corporaciones públicas también se
liberalizaron prácticamente por completo
la inversión extranjera directa las
exportaciones las importaciones la
repatriación de beneficios la entrada y
salida de capitales y la conversión de
la moneda nacional el zloty en divisa
extranjera y la ley de aduanas creó un
tipo único y uniforme aplicable a todas
las empresas públicas o privadas
y no sólo eso además eliminaron los
controles de precios muchas de las
subvenciones que el estado repartía por
doquier se flexibilizó el mercado
laboral e incluso para los inversores
extranjeros más desconfiados se
estableció una garantía del cien por
cien de la inversión en caso de
expropiación y por supuesto se puso en
marcha un plan para privatizar las
empresas públicas y muchas de las
propiedades del gobierno
todo esto se puso en marcha amigos
prácticamente de la noche a la mañana y
aunque os puede resultar sorprendente el
apoyo a las medidas que en muchos casos
ojo iban a conllevar muchas dificultades
durante un tiempo fue enorme para que os
hagáis una idea en ese momento la
percepción que tenían los polacos era
que lo único que les alejaba de la
prosperidad y el sistema social
comunista así que cuanto más rápido
fuera derribado y sustituido pues mejor
para todos claro que llegados a este
punto puede que muchos os estáis
haciendo una pregunta vale vale todo
esto estaba muy bien pero estas
economías se basaban en explotaciones
públicas la mayoría de los factores
productivos pertenecían al estado así
que en otras palabras qué demonios
ocurrió con estos emporios públicos pues
bien veámoslo
los gigantes públicos
[Música]
amigos evidentemente el dominio de las
empresas públicas en la polonia de 1989
era prácticamente total y es que querían
tres estamos hablando de países con
modelos de socialismo duro precisamente
por eso en un primer momento no fueron
precisamente pocos por no decir que eran
la mayoría los economistas y analistas
que consideraban que el paso clave en la
transición de estos países eran la
transformación del sector público y es
que como todos sabéis las empresas
públicas suelen tener muchos problemas
problemas de incentivos de cambio de
costes etcétera etcétera por ejemplo
echemos un vistazo al caso de los
astilleros polacos
los astilleros polacos estaban
controlados por las agencias de
planificación central no tenían un
enfoque global así que para garantizar
la carga de trabajo cada astillero
construya todo tipo de barcos es decir
lo estaban especializados y eran poco
eficientes además tenían estructuras de
costes muy infladas y muchos más
empleados de los que realmente hubieran
necesitado el resultado es que eran
máquinas de perder dinero cuyo
mantenimiento le costaba a un dineral al
estado porque dependían no de vender
barcos sino de los subsidios del
gobierno
[Música]
y claro el problema es cambiar estas
cosas pues es difícil los gestores
estaban habituados a lidiar con los
burócratas del estado no a competir en
el mercado llenar contratos en la
productividad estaba por los suelos de
hecho era menos de una cuarta parte de
la productividad de los astilleros de
países como corea japon o incluso china
los incentivos iban por mantener el
modelo y no por cambiarlo etcétera
etcétera así todo
así que en cualquier caso si polonia
puso en marcha un plan de privatización
y reestructuración sin embargo lo más
llamativo de este modelo particular es
que en la transición polaca todo esto
fue casi irrelevante y es que veréis las
reformas impulsadas por el plan by zero
bits generaron tal dinamismo que al
final las grandes protagonistas del
cambio fueron las nuevas y pequeñas y
medianas empresas que de repente
crecieron como setas mientras la
reestructuración y privatización de los
grandes colosos públicos avanzaba
lentamente la nueva economía privada
despegó con tanta fuerza aquí para 1994
cerca de 2 millones de empresas y
negocios privados y eran responsables ya
de casi cojo la mitad de todo el empleo
no agrícola del país y amigos los
resultados los resultados no van pie a
la duda atentos
[Música]
los resultados
nota alta sobresaliente casi matrícula
de honor amigos
esa es la nota que podemos darle a la
transformación de polonia
y es que veréis la crisis derivada del
cambio de modelo fue muy corta a pesar
del desmoronamiento de casi todas las
instituciones del país en apenas seis
años el pp ya se había recuperado del
todo polonia comenzó entonces una etapa
de crecimiento ininterrumpido que sólo
se ha frenado puntualmente por el
coronavirus casi 30 años después en 1999
el pib por la colla era un 20 por ciento
superior al de 1989 y la actividad
comercial despegó como cohete
[Música]
y no solo la actividad comercial la
inversión extranjera directa comenzó a
llover sobre el país en cantidades
gigantescas en 1998 por ejemplo polonia
trajo ni más ni menos que el 40 por
ciento de todos los flujos de inversión
extranjera directa que fueron a parar a
europa del este
[Música]
estas que veis en pantalla fueron por
ejemplo algunas de las multinacionales
que más invirtieron en el país
en fin amigos ya lo veis así es como
comenzó la historia de éxito que 30 años
después ha hecho que polonia se acerque
a países como portugal o incluso españa
así es la forma en la que polonia
abandonó el comunismo de la noche a la
mañana bajo lo que se conoce como la
terapia del shock eso sí las reformas
continuaron incluyendo en 1999 una
amplia reforma sanitaria basada en
proveedores privados y una completa
reforma del sistema de pensiones donde
se introdujeron elementos de
capitalización pero tal vez con todo lo
más llamativo del caso polaco es que
ningún gobierno ni uno solo ha dado
marcha atrás a las reformas por mercado
que fueron impulsadas por gobiernos
anteriores no está mal verdad pero dicho
esto turno para ti qué te parece en este
tipo de cambios tan abruptos crees que
el modelo polaco podría servir en cierta
forma de referencia para muchos países
con problemas como por ejemplo no sé
quizás argentina déjanos tu respuesta
aquí abajo en los comentarios y ya sabes
si este vidente resulta interesante no
olvides darle al hay que suscribirte a
visual político una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]